I've got the completed long division on
the board and there's a couple of things
I want you to notice if you have a
closer look at what I've worked here and
you compare it to yours for almost all
of you you might be tempted to look at
my working and say mr. Wu you are
cheating that's not what I'm supposed to
/ that's not the original function did
you notice I'm not dividing through by
I'm not dividing rather minus X cubed
minus 6x squared plus X plus 30 that's
not what I'm divining I'm dividing
something else I'm dividing exactly the
opposite of that you might say that's
not fair like I had to deal with all
these minus signs and they were gross
and difficult right well I know that
about myself that I often make you know
mistakes you know doing when I'm dealing
with all of these minus signs there's so
many minus signs there's lots of you're
subtracting minus signs you're just kind
of asking for it right this is like like
I often do a lot of travel so I know to
pack the day before I need to go
somewhere even if I am leaving in the
evening I'll still pack the night before
because I know what happens to my strict
brain when I pack on the day I have to
leave
I always forget something every time
right so part of being a sound
mathematician is knowing methods that
are error-prone and knowing what to do
what strategy to take to avoid those
error-prone methods can you see on my
first line of working what I did what do
I do yeah yeah that negative that's like
causing problems me I just factored it
out now it hasn't disappeared I'm gonna
return to it later on okay but what I've
done is taken it out of the running for
when I'm actually doing the division and
there's just far less chance for you to
make mistakes do you all agree with my
quotient that I've ended up with in my
remainder thumbs up so at this point
this is actually the hardest part of it
I can now use this division to say why
is not just equal to that thing that we
started with but minus sign at the front
cuz that's what I did on my first line
and now I can write the factorization
that I came up with from my divisor and
my quotient so here they go X plus 3 x
squared plus 3 X minus 10 who's already
factorize the quadratic yeah good
plus three X minus two
do I have some agreement forever yep
thumbs up very happy okay we've got
strains approval so we know we're in a
good spot okay great now you might
notice at this point we have something
very similar to what we had before it's
all nice and neatly factorized so I can
read off immediately what the three
routes that I'm expecting are could
anyone tell me what they are
yeah negative 3 negative 5 and 2 okay so
so I've got other routes but the one
difference between this guy and the
other one apart from the values is
there's that negative out the front and
do you remember we looked at these two
which are kind of our stereotypical
cubic graphs not every graph looks
exactly like these but the vast majority
this minus sign at the front which one
am i dealing with it's this this guy
right sorry I had to draw them every
redo them that's why there invest order
I know it's the bottom one because when
you start putting in some huge values
into this right like x equals a hundred
or a thousand you get really big numbers
and then a minus sign hanging out the
front so you get like negative a million
negative a billion you are dropping off
the bottom of this cliff right so that's
why you know it's going to be this one
and from here all that needs to be done
is to pop everything onto a Cartesian
plane so I didn't draw enough of the
left-hand side I'm gonna fix that that's
better
so I'm going to go 1 2 3 4 5 and then 1
2 do please make sure that when you're
plotting your x-intercepts that you have
like a decent set of scale there that's
actually one of the things we're
particularly at four I'm gonna go all
the way through here going to draw a
nice the curve except I've got to start
high and I'm gonna end low okay so I'm
getting something I guess like this I've
done better but I'm happy with that okay
should also put those values on what's
my y-intercept
- okay I could get them to her couldn't
I it's a it's a well how do we usually
find for anything how do we find a y
intercept we let we let X equal zero
right and when you put X equal zero into
our regional function that's probably
the easiest one right
you could put X equal zero to any of
these but I think that's the most
obvious one cuz Bam Bam Bam they all
disappear you end up with that positive
30 okay
so there that's a 30 done skis okay now
for number three I'm actually gonna skip
forward a little bit cuz I notice a few
of you have actually given it a go
Murray and you've actually gone to a
factorization
you've got done your division right and
then you've got what is it X plus two
what is the quadratic you ended up with
is the other factor sin where you got it
I'm sure yeah oh yeah this one that's a
great question okay so if you didn't
catch the chance question its Sean was
asking if you label this graph what
should we label it as like should we
label it is this or that or which one
the short answer is it actually doesn't
matter because they are all the whole
point of us doing this is they're all
the same equation just out of instinct I
would probably just label it in the way
they gave it to me so I would label that
is minus X cubed minus 6x squared plus X
plus 30
that's my instinct but honestly because
they're all equivalent it's fine
whichever you choose okay good question
did someone else has someone got the
other factor on here I know if you've
you've already calculated it's they
don't really just share it with me it
starts with an x squared minus X plus 1
thank you very much Jermaine so I want
you all now regardless of whether you've
done this question or not just look at
this with me okay this is what happens
after you go all the way through the
long division I'm not gonna rehearse
that for you I think you're fine with it
but what's different about this question
have a look at x squared minus X plus 1
just they're really harder there for you
it's the factorization in that guy
shabam is shaking her head at me chef oh
why are you shaking your head of a saint
nice and loud so we can all hear is is
this is this a perfect square it's very
close to a perfect square what would I
change this number into to making a
perfect square and then a negative to
right and then I could factorize that'd
be fine
this is not bad though what is the
factorization oh this guy doesn't want
to be factorized at least not with the
tools that we have right you can try and
complete the square on this guy you can
try and put the quadratic formula the
way I know in fact the way I crafted
this question was I want you to think
back to this guy what is this this is
the discriminant right for this just the
quadratic just look at the quadratic
right what is the discriminant going to
be for that particular quadratic I start
with what's the first thing in the
discriminant b squared in this case b
squared is 1 because negative 1 times
thinking 1 then I get what what comes
after the b squared minus 4ac now in
this case a and C are both 1 so minus
4ac is just minus 4 and I don't even
need to work out what that number is I
already know it's negative this doesn't
have this doesn't have real roots okay
now what does that mean I can't do like
it says divide by the gear in fact to
complete the factorization that's the
complete factorization so you like what
am I supposed to do I've got one root
for this it's negative 2 and I don't
have any roots from this what does that
mean for the graph so in the previous
ones right we found 2 sorry three
x-intercepts we found 3 for the other
one you found one here that's because
that's the only one there's only a
single x-intercept
ok so invite you now if you haven't
already enjoy yourself up that third set
of axes please you could do this with me
together third set of axes please
we've already determined where that
x-intercept is so we're gonna go
negative 1 negative 2 so I'm gonna
where's that gonna go I'll check that
value there because I've got no more
x-intercepts I'm like oh that's all I
have at the moment I feel like I need
more information here right what other
piece of information can you work out
easily I've got an X except I can work
in a wider sense what is it it's just
positive 2 right because all of these
terms just going to become 0 when you
substitute in x equals 0 so let's put
plus 2 here I still feel like I don't
have very much about this right like
I've just got these two spots I feel
like I need more information right would
someone like to give me a suggestion for
a value I can try out hey I want to
suggest I could try an x equals 1 that's
a nice easy number to put that's 1 plus
1 minus 1 plus 2 so what a minus 1 in
the middle they're gonna cancel out so
you just gonna get 1 plus 2 what's that
3 so that's somewhere like if I said
that's 1 3 there you go yeah you can
keep going you get some more information
on this I know I'm roughly gonna get
which of these shapes top or bottom
this guy here because it's the look at
the number from the X cubes you see that
that's the real key in fact it's so
important we given a name we call it the
leading coefficient it's positive that's
right so if it were negative it would go
down but it's positive okay so you're
gonna get a shape that's kind of I
actually think I'd love you to just
chuck this into desmos but I think
you're getting a shape like this ok now
I actually need some more information to
know exactly where these Wiggles around
I don't know where that is at the moment
but you can at the moment the only tool
we've got is to throw a few more points
in there honestly to find out what's
going on okay